[Musique]
à travers Paris par un ciel amoureux si
bleu je m'en suis allé dans l'éclat de
l'été
heureux mon cœur trop plein de
joie
d'éclater de dire à n'importe qui
n'importe quoi tout d'un coup sans
raison comme un fou j'ai longtemps gardé
durant tout un hiver
sévère les chants du bonheur prisonniers
de mon cœur hier
et soudain au
jouri il faut bien qu'il s'enfu de moi
par ma voix d'ù jaillit ma
[Musique]
joie ma joie vole vers toi ma joie
attrapela pour notre
avenir au rendez-vous donné la vie a
décidé de nous
réuni à travers Paris par un ciel
amoureux tous
deux nous avons marché dans l'éclat de
l'été heureux
mon cœur trop plein de toi était prêt
d'éclater de dire à n'importe qui que je
t'aimais Je t'aimais comme un fou pour
jamais bien main dans la main dans le
soleil riant et
tendre au diable demain nous avons bien
le temps
d'apprendre tout ce qu''est la
vie pas toujours
jolie demain demain nous verrons bien
bien bien à travers Paris à travers
Paris à travers Paris à travers
[Musique]
Paris